ثلاثه ملايين وخمسمائه الف هنا سماع عدده
سكان اوروغواي ومتوسط ودخل الفجر في 2021
17 الف دولار
فازت بكاس العالم في عام 1930 ورقم صعب في
الكره حتى الان لكن هناك دول اخرى تمتلك
ثروه بشريه واقتصاديه اكبر بكثير لا
تمتلكوه منتخبات الصف الاول لكره القدم
دول عظمى كثيره مثل الولايات المتحده
والصين تفوقت في العاب كثيره لكن لم تحقق
ذات النجاح في الرياضه الاكثر شعبيه
الاهتمام الشعبي ليس كبيرا بالعوده لعام
في المئه فقط من الصين لعبوا كره القدم
بالمقارنه مع عدد السكان اكثر من مليار
و400 مليون نسمه لكن رغم ذلك بكين كما ان
لديها خطه سياسيه ضخمه لديها هدف مع كروي
التحول لقوه عظمى بحلول عام 2050 كيف مثلا
خطط تتضمن بناء 20 الف مركز التدريبن
الجديد بناء اكبر اكاديميه كره قدم عالميه
في اجوانزو بتكلفه 285 مليون دولار